so you just want to redo your vacation  from 30 years ago don't you think that's  gonna be kind of a letdown no no no  we're not redoing anything this will be  completely different for one thing the  original vacation had a boy and a girl  this one has two boys and I'm sure that  there will be lots of other differences  what's what's happened to you since high  school everything good military yeah  really that's true no military straight  out of school two tours and then I got  out of there you know it's just saying  I've done a lot of things remain inside  the ride at all times  don't blow up  that's what I want to hear before going  into another mission  Oh  you